Hi, welcome to this my final session in
the investment philosophies class. So
let's gather together what we have up
till this point. I started this class by
saying that there's no one best
investment philosophy, but there's one
that's right for you. And to find it,
you need to know who you are as a
person, what your financial
characteristics are, and find that best
fit. If you try and invest in
philosophy, no matter how well it's
worked for other people, that doesn't
match you as a person, doesn't match
your needs, I can almost guarantee you
that it'll fail. For whatever reason,
it's difficult to sustain a philosophy
that doesn't match your needs. So, let's
start looking at some of the things you
might want to keep an inventory of to
decide what philosophy works for you.
First, you have to ask yourself, are you
patient or not? And you might want to
ask the people closest to you because
you might call yourself patient but you
might get a very different impression to
the people around you. The truth is some
of us are born more impatient than
others. You can't change that. If you
adopt a strategy or philosophy that
requires a long time horizon and you're
an impatient person, how is that going
to work out for you? Second, you want to
check out your risk aversion. Are you
risk averse? And I know you can take
tests to see how riskaverse you are. But
often the measure of risk aversion is
how uncomfortable are you with what
you've invested in. The more
uncomfortable you are, the more you're
signaling to yourself, this doesn't
match my risk aversion. Third, are you
an individual or a group thinker? again
with no no labels attached to you. Some
of us want to hang out with our peers
and want their their approval and others
amongst us are more more willing to take
them on and do the opposite. And again,
we're you know some of us are more born
more interested in one other than the
other and trying to pick a philosophy
that makes you what you're not, it's not
going to work. So if you are a group
thinker, you like to go along with a
pair, you want their approval, that
being a contrarian is going to be really
difficult for you to be. How much time
do you have available to spend on
investing? If you have a job as an
engineer or a doctor and you spend 12
hours a day on your job, you can't pick
an investment philosophy that requires
you to spend six more hours a day
picking stocks. And finally, your age
does matter. Less than many wealth
managers think, but it does. If you're
30 years old, you can invest in a in
things that might go wrong but correct
themselves over time, but you might not
be able to do the same thing when you're
65 years old. So, as you age, your needs
change, your time horizon changes, and
that's got to be factored into your
decision process. So, those are the
personal characteristics and the signs
of a misfit where you pick a philosophy
that doesn't match your personality.
Here are my three tests. The first is
what I call the sleep test. I know it's
incredibly unsophisticated, but it works
for me every time. If you lie awake at
night wondering what's in your portfolio
and how it's doing, you fail the sleep
test. My measure of a sleep test is when
you when you pick your portfolio and you
go to bed, your portfolio shouldn't even
be on the top 10 list of things you go
through. You should be able to sleep
through the night. If you pick a
philosophy that or a portfol or or a
portfolio that keeps you awake at night,
I mean, what have you accomplished? You
might have slightly higher returns, but
you're going to have cardiac arrests and
ulcers to deal deal with as a
consequence. My second sign of a misfit
is what I call the life changed days. If
your investments are such that if one of
them fails, you have to change the way
you live. You got to move houses, pull
your kids out of the the schools they're
in, move locations. It's not worth it.
You want to make sure that nothing you
do puts what the way you live to a test.
And third, you want don't want to do
things which where you constantly second
guessess what you did. I have two things
that I you know two two acronyms that I
used Romo and FOMO. Romo's regret over
missing out. FOMO is fear of missing
out. It's amazing how much time
investors spend in those two spaces. The
less time you spend in those two spaces,
the healthier investing will be. And one
sign of an investment philosophy is how
much time you're spending in those
spaces. Now, in terms of financial
characteristics, what are the things
that matter? Your job security matters.
The amount of money you have to invest
matters. How much cash you need matters.
And your tax status matters. All of
those things will change over time. So
clearly your philosophy should also
shift as those characteristics change.
Many wealth managers as I noted when you
walk in and ask for advice. The first
thing they ask you is how old you are.
And many of them base what your
investing should be on entirely on your
age. I think that's that's a shortcut
that'll often lead you to bad choices.
It is one element of what you got to
factor in, but it can't be everything.
So let's look at how each of these
factors plays out in your investment
philosophy choice. Let's start with job
security. Most people who invest have
other jobs that they have. Doctors, as
engineers, as lawyers, and those jobs
come with different demands, but it's
well established that during a
recession, even people with secure jobs
worry about their jobs and demand larger
risk premiums. And if you're insecure
about your job, you can't afford to take
as much risk in your portfolio. I'm
stating the obvious, but might as well
state it. Now, what you invest in will
also be determined by what your
perception is of your future earnings
capacity. If you believe that you have
going to make a lot of money and you're
going to continue to make a lot of money
over the rest of your life, you will
invest very differently from somebody
who has a lower ceiling on how much they
can make and much more variability over
time in what they make. So, your job
security matters. The type of job you
have matters in terms of what investment
philosophy you pick. Of course, your job
might be managing other people's money.
In which case, we'll talk about what you
should do. But if your job is affecting
your investing, it is natural. It's the
way it should be. Second, how much money
do you have to invest? Now, to the
extent that you're investing your own
money, the the choices you have will
start to expend depending on how much
money you have to invest. If you have
only $10,000 to invest, there are far
fewer things you can do than if you have
$10 million to invest. But when you
think about how much money you have to
invest, don't just restrict yourself to
your savings because you might also have
money in pension funds or IRA or
insurance savings accounts that have to
be factored in and they're invested in
places that have to be brought into the
process. And finally, you know, to the
extent that you might be restricted on
some of those choices, some pension
funds might might restrict you three or
four choices. Those might determine what
you can do with the rest of your money.
So, if your pension fund forces you to
invest in the S&P 500, then with the
rest of your money, you get a lot more
leeway to invest in small cap stocks or
alternative investments to round out
your overall portfolio. Third, when you
look at the future, you have to think
about demands for cash that will show up
which are unanticipated. Like what? You
could get sick and you might need to
cover healthcare. Uh your children might
need to switch schools with a higher
tuition. That's got to be factored in.
So when you have unpredictable demands
for cash, it has to be factored ahead of
the fact into your portfolio that you
might have those demands. If you're a
portfolio manager, this shows up in a
different way. your clients can change
their minds and want their money back.
You're saying, "What's the big deal?" As
a portfolio manager, then you got to set
aside enough liquidity being enough
liquid investments that you can meet
their needs.
So, you might not know exactly what
those cash withdrawals will be or when
they will happen, but the probability of
it happening will affect your
philosophy.
Finally, your tax status matters because
you get to spend after tax returns. When
you face high taxes, then that's got to
be factored into what you invest in, the
strategies you adopt. It might not
affect your philosophy as much as it
affects your strategies. What makes this
complicated is you might face different
tax issues with different parts of your
portfolio. On your pension fund, for
instance, you might not be taxed at all.
You can afford to invest in high
dividend paying stocks, but on your
savings, you might be taxed on an on an
annual basis. So you got to be more
careful about what you invest in and
what it does to your taxable income that
year. So the kind of job you hold, how
much money you have to invest, cash
needs which are unpredictable, tax
status, all play into what kind of
philosophy you pick. And finally, what
you believe about markets is going to
drive the philosophy you pick. Now you
you're saying, "How do I come up with
market beliefs?" Some of it comes from
anecdotal evidence. Let's face it, the
stories you're told about markets will
find their way into your beliefs. Now,
in this in in this class, we've looked
at the empirical data, not as if it's
going to give you an absolute answer to
any of this, but it goes beyond the
anecdotal evidence to see if
historically this particular strategy
has delivered returns. Your views on
markets will change over time, though.
Mine have over the last 40 years based
on what? Based on what I observe in
markets. Sometimes things that I thought
were true 40 years ago are no longer the
things I hold on to. But staying
consistent in investing philosophy and
your core beliefs is central to
investing success in my view. So get a
sense of how markets behave and your if
your reaction is I don't know enough
that's okay. Form your beliefs based on
what you know today. Revisit those
beliefs as you get to learn more and let
experience drive what those beliefs will
be a year from now, two years from now,
5 years from now.
In this table, I'm trying to capture all
of the different philosophies we've
covered in this book. And I've
classified them based on two dimensions.
One is where the markets are driven by
momentum. I, you know, they've gone up,
they continue to go up. go down. You
continue to go down by reversal which is
contrarian or opportunistic
which is okay can cut in both ways but
you can catch mistakes when you find
them and based on time horizon
short-term medium-term long-term and you
can use your own definitions to to to be
comfortable and you can see the
philosophies range from stock picking to
market timing to arbitrage to activist
growth and active growth investing. You
can pick a philosophy and not I'm not
going to put any of these philosophies
as I said as the best philosophy. Pick
the one that works for you given all of
the criteria we've talked about
the right investment philosophy is the
one that best fits you. Okay. So you can
either go with that single philosophy
but we've also opened the door that
sometimes there might be two or three
philosophies that can cohabit in the
same person. You might be a a deep value
investor as your core philosophy but
also believe that in markets overreact
to bad news and add information trading
as a component. So you know those are
complimentary philosophy they're driven
by fundamentally the same beliefs about
market about markets that markets know
push out too much one in one case you're
taking advantage of the long-term payoff
from that the other short term. Now, my
only advice is don't mix philosophies or
strategies and make contradictory
assumptions about market behavior over
the same period because those will be in
conflict with each other. So, when you
combine strategies, make sure you're
drawing on the same beliefs about
markets and make sure that you in your
mind know what your dominant strategy
is. From the example I gave about about
investing in deep value and trading on
information, make a judgment as to what
the lead philosophy is and what the
complimentary philosophy is because that
should govern where you spend your time.
So in closing,
the best way to find an investment
philosophy is look within. So rather
than read books on successful investors,
spend some time thinking about what
makes you comfortable, what makes you
uncomfortable, and find a philosophy
that fits you.
and your choice of philosophy will be
affected by what you believe about
markets, how old you are, you know, all
of those things we talked about. That's
part of the reason I am not an
absolutist. I'm not going to go around
judging people based on how they invest
because it's none of my business.
You choose your philosophy based on what
you believe. I would choose my
philosophy based on what I believe and
may maybe both way. I hope you found
these sessions useful and I hope you
find a way to learn investment
philosophy that best fits you. Thank you
very much for listening.